[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Natalia plazas
hoy en reemplazo de Álvaro cordero Este
24 de febrero se cumple el primer
aniversario del inicio de la guerra en
Ucrania un conflicto que comenzó tras la
invasión de Rusia pero que es imposible
de comprender sin analizar la historia
de estas dos naciones en France 24
repasamos los orígenes de esta guerra y
la relación de estos dos países desde el
final de La Unión soviética en 1991
Ucrania fue durante décadas una
República perteneciente a la urso pero
sus aspiraciones cambiaron con el
desmoronamiento de la gran potencia
socialista el sentimiento secesionista
empezó a tomar fuerza a inicios de la
década de 1990 y culminó el primero de
diciembre de 1991 cuando los ucranianos
apoyaron la independencia con el 90% de
los votos su primer presidente como
nación independiente fue leoney Craft
pero la independencia arrastró varios
desde el inicio el primero la profunda
crisis económica que todo el bloque
posoviético sufrió Durante los años 90 y
el segundo las dos realidades del país
la parte occidental tenía un carácter
nacionalista ucraniano que tendía
acercarse a la Unión Europea pero la
Oriental comenzó a sentir nostalgia de
Rusia una cuestión que se enquistó aún
más desde 1994 con la victoria
presidencial de leonic cusma un político
que enfrentó numerosas críticas por su
acercamiento a Rusia esto opinaba Putin
de su relación en 2001
estamos manteniendo y restableciendo
lazos anteriormente rotos en relación
con los intereses fundamentales tanto de
Rusia como de Ucrania
para el final del mandato de cusma la
fractura entre los defensores de acercar
Ucrania a la Unión Europea y los
nostálgicos de Moscú se hicieron
evidentes y así se llegó a las
elecciones de 2004 Víctor joshenko el
candidato pre-euu se enfrentó a Víctor
yanukovic en una campaña marcada por la
polémica ya no covich contó con todo el
apoyo del expresidente cutsma y de Moscú
en 2004 siete naciones del Antiguo
bloque soviético se unieron a la otan y
Rusia temía el mismo destino para
Ucrania por lo que intervino de lleno la
campaña se ensució hasta el término de
que yushenko fue envenenado con dioxina
y que el día de los comicios yanukovic
fue dado por vencedor a pesar de tener
menos votos como respuesta al fraude
electoral de cientos de miles de
ucranianos salieron a las calles a
partir del 22 de noviembre de 2004 para
rechazar el nombramiento de yanukovic
estas protestas fueron conocidas como la
revolución naranja y forzaron a la Corte
Suprema de Ucrania a denegar el
resultado electoral fraudulento que daba
como vencedora llanocovich obligando que
se realizara una repetición de la
segunda vuelta una votación que dio de
forma definitiva la victoria ayuchenco
durante 14 años hemos sido
independientes pero ahora de una sola
vez Hemos llegado a ser libres hoy
decimos adiós a los viejos tiempos los
tiempos de la deshonestidad la censura y
la violencia
su gobierno estuvo marcado por un
acercamiento a la Unión Europea y por
tensiones con Rusia que llevaron a
cortes esporádicos de gas pero los
ucranianos decidieron darle la espalda
en las elecciones de 2009 y apoyar al
que había sido su anterior rival Víctor
yanukovic desde 2010 el giro de Ucrania
fue otra vez hacia el kremlin algo que
hizo que las tensiones explotaran
definitivamente en noviembre de 2013
yanucovich rechazó un acuerdo de
asociación con la Unión Europea por
presiones de Moscú y por ello cientos de
miles de personas salieron a las calles
para protestar contra el presidente fue
el inicio del euro maidan el euromaidan
supuso un antes y un después para
Ucrania las protestas no se dieron y
yanucovich respondió con violencia algo
que forzó su destitución por el
parlamento en febrero de 2014 a partir
de ese momento la política ucraniana dio
un giro de 180 grados para alejarse de
Rusia y esto tuvo consecuencias crimea
de mayoría rusa convocó un referendo
ilegal para separarse de Ucrania en
marzo de ese año y posteriormente se
unió a Rusia un método similar que dos
meses después se replicó en las regiones
de duni que anunciaron su independencia
de Ucrania
algo que quien nunca aceptó y llevó a
que en el este del país iniciase una
guerra entre Ucrania y las fuerzas
separatistas prorrusas el conflicto se
prolongó durante años las fuerzas
ucranianas fueron incapaces de doblegar
por completo a la separatistas y el
frente se estancó dejando cientos de
muertos en las regiones de doneski
luganska las dos partes intentaron
negociar la paz en acuerdos como los
acuerdos de Minsk y alcanzaron varios
saltos el fuego pero nunca fueron
respetados el conflicto se mantuvo
estancado hasta que a finales de 2021
Rusia elevó la atención concentrando
tropas en las fronteras ucranianas
fueron meses de incertidumbre hasta que
Putin decidió el 22 de febrero de 2022
reconocer a las repúblicas separatistas
el reconocimiento de esta República
viene dictado por el hecho de que los
dirigentes de kiev en Ucrania
no van a aplicar estos acuerdos de memes
dos días después Rusia decidió invadir
Ucrania por varios puntos el resto es
sobradamente conocido ya en este año de
guerra decenas de miles de personas han
muerto y millones de ucranianos se han
visto forzados a desplazarse o
refugiarse en el extranjero
Rusia ha fracasado en el intento de
hacerse con la mayoría del país pero
domina una buena parte del Don vast y
del sureste ucraniano y la guerra
aparece estar lejos de terminar con esto
concluimos Gracias por comentar y
compartir estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de France 24
y France 24.com
[Música]